phil's left-hander matt moore making his
10th start of the season 1-3 with a 6.79
era
2-2 pitch swing and a miss and he got
him
one batter one out here in the first and
the first strikeout recorded by matt
moore and a good way to start
so the count remains 0-2 and there he
goes
that is the strikeout that they were
looking for the second one of the inning
and the final out here in the top of the
first they face luis castillo and the
reds hope that luis castillo is not the
castillo that they saw in cleveland when
he gave a big run
oh and that is 101 from castillo
blows it by jt rio muta
motto a short lead off first
that one is hit on the ground diving
stop by didi gregorius over the second
for one over the first double play you
will not see a better double play than
that
six four three
talk about some defense staying alive i
think they're going to take a look and
see if it's in the first base but just
to even get to it didi gregorius
outstanding job
fred's wasting no time to take a beat
how do you do it
remarkable
yeah they are going to look at the play
at first
but man oh man
he can do damage
he hits that one on the ground to deity
a little bit easier play steps on second
for one over the first that is a double
play and that will stay reno therese
will get a shot to make his mark against
luis castillo he'll step in from the
right side
he's swung on and that one is hit well
deep down the left field line and that
is gone
a home run
and theres does make his mark
number six on the season and the fills
have a one-nothing lead
roto doing his thing
it's truly remarkable
where would this ball club be
without ronald truray yes
what a swing get that foot down good
extension
tucks it inside the fair pole one
nothing good guys
it'll be the top of the order for the
cincinnati reds
swinging a miss synagogue so india
strikes out again
and it is the
fourth strikeout for matt moore see that
knuckle curve india's fifth strikeout
and six at bats and that will bring up
joey votto
hill two pitch swinging a miss and he
got him
nice job right there on the change-up
for matt moore and he gets vatto
swinging through it and gets
through the fourth inning with no damage
done
and that one is a lined shot and
squeezed by ronald teres
ronnie on the spot right there yeah
that's poor planting on suarez's part
another one pitch one out nice play may
have to tighten up that webbing after
that rocket
last time he went five plus big swing
and a miss
and another strikeout for matt moore
that's a good cutter seven strikeouts
that is a good cutter
late breaking
naked not even close
he's flailing at it
swinging a miss and he got him another
strikeout for matt moore and he is
through six
not allowing the base hit so far
herrera he got that and more
as if double hits that one spinning on
the ground third baseman suarez has it
and oh double beats it out easily that
was a tough play for suarez with two
outs jt real mutual
and he swings that's a line drive into
right field that's gonna score a run
it's gonna get in the gap jt is thinking
two here comes the throw
not in time and it's a double for real
muto and rbi as well and the phillies
lead it two to nothing
and a nice easy swing
[Music]
hitting where the pitch is pitched
[Music]
that's a big run for the fills
a little bit surprising that hector
nearest is the new pitcher gerardi
making the decision that uh he's gotten
all he can adam at moore now he's gonna
turn to his bullpen to try and keep it
right here
makes light work of nick castiano's
good morning good afternoon good night
night indeed
slider fastball fastball some paint
a one-two pitch swing and a miss
senor lancidor getting the job done for
sure
two strikeouts in that inning ten
pitches and it's
and he lays down a bun and it's a beauty
no play anywhere and suarez just has to
pick it up and eat it are you kidding me
you can't do it any better than that
baseball player
so that will bring up travis jankowski
he swings in that one base it to left
field
here comes the runner home brad miller
being sent home the throw to the plane
is
not in time
and thereas moves up the third
rbi single for travis jankowski and the
phillies lead at three to nothing
so let's take another look
it looks like it caught aquino off guard
throw was wide i mean from that angle he
looks safe let's take another look look
at this angle brad miller has to take
the home plate and it's impossible to
tell there i mean he does get the tag on
the leg but was his hand on the plate in
time here this might give us a better
[Applause]
oh he's safe they can't overturn that
reds are trailing it three to nothing
and are still looking for their first
hit
3-1
stevenson clocks it deep right field
bryce harper bends back no-no is gone
the reds are on the board
tyler stevenson opposite way a solo shot
and the reds within two
i love the fact that tyler stevenson is
committed to hitting the ball to right
field and when you've got that kind of
size and strength in that ballpark
anything is possible the aforementioned
bryce harper will step to the plate
swung on line driving to right center
field that one is going to get into the
gap and go all the way to the wall
jt real mutual rounding third he's going
to come in and score harpers standing up
at third it's an rbi triple here in the
eighth for bryce harper
and now the ball is loose no one's
covering home plate and harper will
score
heads up base running by bryce harper
and the phillies get two the old little
league homer and two runs scored
not the best effort there by castiano's
fake queen gets it in and the ball just
ends up in no man's land
i don't know what farmer's doing
anything he's throwing it to botto
and then barnhart stuck in the middle
like what do i do
and harper scores easily wow
you acknowledge
dusty wasn't even getting to see it at
first you know give bryce heads up
because he saw that ball time had not
been called he's already acknowledging
the bench
and that'll bring up andrew mccutcher
deep to left field that one will go
andrew mccutchen a solo shot
number 21 on the season for catch
and the phillies now lead it six to one
from the belt the one-two pitch swung on
popped up
left side to reyes long run in the foul
territory
makes the catch and this ball game is
over
phillies will win it six to one this
afternoon
outstanding pitching some timely hitting
and some great defense that is a recipe
for wins for sure